joining me now is Kevin McGary
co-founder of every black life matters
and president of the Frederick Douglas
Foundation of California and Horus
Cooper author and legal commentator
Kevin you know it's extremely sad uh for
everyone the the the victims mostly but
also for uh a lot of these uh young
people in urban America especially who
are taught that victimhood pays and that
violence is actually just a you know a
perfectly fine Instinct what has to
happen
next yeah thank you for having me Laura
it is a uh what we're seeing is a
complete uh undermining of all of the
systems we see the undermining of family
we undermining of Education by our
children being propagandized to and
brainwashed into thinking that
everything uh has to do with uh you know
colonialists and supremists that have
taken over all of our major all all of
the money and all of the jobs and
therefore you're a victim you know you
you you know you got to go out and get
yours because they're the ones who have
taken your opportunity and these are
messages that have been uh postulated
now for the past two generations I would
say and right now they're really hitting
stride so this is all part of a uh you
know a Marxist kind of cultural Marxist
kind of uh stream that we're in now
where we see the the outcomes that are
wholly disproportionate we don't even
see certain types of crimes being uh you
know as you've so eloquently stated we
don't even see certain types of crimes
being uh talked about because they're
it's an inconvenient narrative
everything is being narrative driven and
they want if they can to to try to get
the races grieved and clashing and
bitter and hateful towards one another
because that is a then then produces
another Cog if you will uh that that
really undermines American and
ultimately you know provides a A system
that is in collapse when it's in
collapse then of course we can go into
the globalist communist stuff yeah yeah
Horus things have gotten so bad in in
Washington DC our nation's capital that
the mayor Muriel Bowser has finally been
forced to try to respond to this crisis
this is what she said I will declare uh
public emergencies to allow uh the
government's response uh especially to
procuring services to be expedited those
issues are opioid overdoses um and the
second issue is youth
violence well Horus I mean she's kind of
stating the problem that we already know
exists but what after that you know the
DC is just has become in large part an
unlivable City because people are scared
in DC and now it's an emergency I say it
was an emergency a long time ago wasn't
it you left out the most exciting clip
where they're going to give out Apple
Air tags so that when your car gets
stolen you can track it down and great
let me figure this out I'm a law-abiding
citizen criminal took my car I'm going
to go and meet my criminal what good can
come from that now I just want to say
this broadly speaking uh this
neo-marxist cultural attack on America
has managed to do what covid couldn't
and that is it has led to a quicker loss
of life for black Americans the age at
which blacks are dying because of the
crime wave is dropping relative to the
rest of the population in fact in 21 and
in 22 the Centers for Disease Control
listed for black Americans something
that it hasn't listed for any other
group it says loss of life by homicide
one of the top 10 causes of death not
for Asians not for whites not for Native
Americans but for black Americans
there's good news though because the the
Open Season that is leading to the CVS
closing in your community so that
grandma has to take a bus to get to pick
up her prescriptions and it costs more
money at this new location the good news
is that black Americans are telling
anyone who will listen they are no
longer staying on the Democrat
Plantation record numbers of black
Americans are showing up on social media
and they're telling posters they're not
going along with this they want the
America that they're F that our Founders
fought for all right Kevin um Democrats
to that point have been beginning to
Hemorrhage black voters here's how the
Biden campaign though responded to what
seems to be a new reality we have to
talk about the mag extremists who want
to roll back the progress that we we've
been able to achieve and so our focus on
a campaign has to be on telling this
message over the course of the next 12
months we have to be honest about the
brick wall of magga extremism that we
continue to run into when we're trying
to get things done for the American
people Kevin does he mean the Maga
extremism that led to record home
ownership by African-Americans or Rising
median incomes or you know in an
enforced border or is that was that the
magga extremism I guess we'll take that
magga extremism yeah uh your reaction is
that going to work
these these ridiculous tropes uh do not
work I mean the reality is your average
black family is feeling it we're feeling
not double digigit inflation in some
cases 3x inflation right every time we
go to the store every time we filling up
our cars we're feeling it uh those those
elderly uh Black Americans that are on
fixed income they're feeling it I mean
they have to somehow accommodate an $800
a month hit because that's your average
American citizen is paying $800 a month
more under the
biomics that we did uh in the prior
Administration it's about $9,600
a year so everyone's feeling it it's
pervasive and and that's what we're
feeling forget the tropes about magga
this and that that's ridiculous we
understand what we have to endure what
we're currently feeling our our ability
and our progy not being able to buy
homes not being able to get Investments
because of interest rates being so high
all of this has a pervasive effect sorry
to interrupt but Horus really quickly
will we see a significant erosion I'd
say 5% or more as a significant erosion
of the black vote in 2024 toward
Republicans blacks are going to vote in
numbers that are going to exceed 15% it
could be close to 20% but it will
definitely exceed 15% making States like
Pennsylvania even New Jersey um
difficult for the left to be able to
carry but they own this the progressives
created this heartbreak in Black America
and Black Americans are standing up and
they're saying no more gentlemen thank
you both hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else